give us an idea of where negotiations
stand right now what's the state of play
as we head into another strike day
well we're in constant dialogue with the
train operating companies in one strand
of talk so with network rail in the
other
we haven't had any new offers from the
companies since the uh a few weeks ago
and in fact for the train operating
companies we've had no offer on pay
but we're continuing to talk to them
about the problems that they they want
to address the issues that what they
call modernization
at our agenda which is to get our
members of pay rise because many of them
had haven't had one for three years and
also to achieve job security but what we
need is the government
who got themselves in a peculiar
position in the last week or two as
we've all seen to change their stance
because the key to unlocking this
problem is for the Department of
Transport and the treasury to change
their stance so that we can get a bit of
good will around the negotiating table
and work up some formulas for resolving
this dispute and I hope that happens
I've met with a new secretary of state
and she you know approached that in a
positive mood we approach that in a
positive mood but we've got to see some
substantial changes
so that we can create an agreement for
all the railway workers and indeed for
the public and the taxpayer who want to
get on with getting a normal Railway
Service as do we
tell me a little bit more about that
meeting with Anne-Marie trevally in the
new transport secretary what was
different do you think about her
approach and do you think it will mean
that you can get a breakthrough
well her predecessor Grant chaps all he
did was go on media rounds and hurl
abuse at trade unionists and me
individually and other Trade union
leaders which is completely unhelpful
and he also gave the companies
uh remits that were impossible to
fulfill because even the senior
Executives in this industry who you know
aren't our friends but we work with them
know that what they were demanding was
impossible for the unions to concede to
so she at least met with us Grant chaps
refused to meet with me and the other
Union uh General secretaries she's got
that out of the way now so that's that's
pretty that that boil and we can get on
with maybe creating some solutions she's
gone into the media last week and said
that she wants to work constructively
I welcome that it doesn't mean that the
the problems are gone we've still got
difficult issues in the industry we've
got difficult issues with the structure
of the industry but we've got to remind
ourselves that the railway companies are
making profits all the time they're
living on subsidy from the taxpayer
which the uh the government is providing
and the bosses of these companies the
railway Rich are extracting millions of
pounds in their salaries and will be
benefiting from this tax break for
millionaires that quasi-quarting
provided last week so I hope that she
changes The Stance of the government and
therefore the stance of the companies
and we can get on with resolving this
dispute our members can get back to work
they can earn their living again and the
the public can expect a good service off
the railway but that's all to to be seen
in the next few weeks well yeah and I
put some of those points I spoke to um
Dan Payne's from the rail delivery agree
which represents uh rail companies in
the last hour and I put some of those
points to him about railway companies
making huge profits for example he said
that it wasn't true that they made big
profits that he said that the profits
that they made wouldn't cover a five
percent uh pay increase for workers and
on the subject of salaries he said that
it's the companies that own the rail
companies where the bosses earn earn a
lot of money what do you say to that
well the first group owns uh the railway
they own this Railway that I'm standing
outside now eventually West Coast they
are creaming in money uh the Rolling
Stock uh leasing companies paid out 75
million pound in dividend in the last
year when there was virtually nobody
traveling on the railway in 2021 because
of the covid instructions to stay at
home there is mass profit being made 500
million pounds in profit was extracted
from the railway last year between
Network rail subcontractors and the
train operators the executives of these
companies are making fortunes and
they've made fortunes since
privatization in
1993 in the mid 90s they have extracted
probably 12 billion pounds of profit
since privatization and when that gets a
bit tight when the com the country's got
difficult is all we went through the
pandemic they don't want to play the
game and what they want to do is extract
that from Railway workers they also want
to milk the public affairs on the on the
railway are extortion nobody's getting a
square deal apart from the executives
and the shareholders of these companies
they are making fortunes and they cannot
lose they have no Capital At Risk in the
new public service contracts they only
get Revenue it's like a royalty every
pound they take in fares they get a
commission from there and there is no
risk to them whatsoever that's why these
strikes are not resolved because they
get indemnified for any losses and
they're getting paid 30 million pounds
every time there is a strike so they've
probably received 200 million pound in
strike pay since this dispute commenced
it's a one-way ticket to wealth for the
super rich and that's got to end there
is a railway rich list and they are
creaming it I can assure you of that
okay and but he tells a different story
but but let's talk about the timing of
this strike as well of course this comes
a day before the London marathon it's
going to be really hard for a lot of
people to get to the starting line
tomorrow morning really disappointing
for people who's trained an awful lot
but also it's a massive charity day
isn't it this is a day that lots of
Charities rely on to raise a huge amount
of funds and they will be feeling
incredibly frustrated the timing of this
strike is is pretty awful for them
well the timing of the strike is a
succession of actions that we started
this process back in March we took our
first action in June so it's a long-term
dispute we don't want the target the
London Marathon we've got no intention
of doing that but the way the
legislation Works in this country the
anti-trade Union laws which we're going
to get more of we have to keep the
disputes going to comply with the law I
hope that the the runners and the
charity collectors and the people that
want to raise money which is a shame
they have to do that it's a shame we
haven't got our Public Services properly
funded and we have to rely on charity
instead I hope that they get to to the
starting line I hope that they could
have a good day tomorrow we don't want
to disrupt them but we have to keep this
dispute going on behalf of our members
it's also the Tory Party Conference
they've got no compunction about
um changing the way that Tax Works in
this country the way that Charities have
to raise money and our action is aimed
quite explicitly at the Tory Party
Conference which is also happening
tomorrow so this dispute will continue
and unfortunate actually there will be
disruption but if we can limit that by
through getting a settlement to the
dispute that's what we'll do and we'll
get everyone back to normal so we do
apologize for that disruption but I'm
afraid it's inevitable in a long-term
dispute whenever we go on strike
somebody or some groups will be
disrupted